年末の
寒くて寂しい一人の夜
彼は今日もパソコンに向かって
カタカタカタカタと
文章を打つのでした
わーーーー！！！！！！！
まだ大丈夫まだ大丈夫だよまだ大丈夫
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
いよいよ
今年もホントに終わりの時期に来たんですけども
それと同時にボクの卒業論文の〆切りも迫ってきてるわけでございます
まだ間に合うまだ間に合う
まだ間に合う
まだ間に合ってほしい
いや、間に合うよ　全然まだ大丈夫なんですよ
もうちょっと期間はあるんですけども
文字数的にも、もう超えてます
一応、提出はできるんですけども
今、軽い修正とかもうちょっとこう直すべき所とかを
ちょいちょいやってるんで
もうねもう本当につめの部分
ただねぇ
焦りますわぁ
あの、ここまで来ると　ちょっとねえ、やっぱりねえ
やっておかなきゃ行けないという感じが強くてね
中々ねちょっと　てかもう
今年中に終わらせるよ？
絶対年内には形にするんで
もうちょっと　もうちょっと　もう、ああんじぇえ　あのもう
動画とってる余裕はちょっとない
って言っちゃウソになる
動画とってる余裕がないと言っては
嘘になるが
あの動画とってる時間があったら
卒業論文書いたほうがいい感じです。
なので今日は卒業論文をやりますね！
ごめんなさい！
ｶﾁｶﾁｶﾁｶﾁ。。。。
と見せかけて
このタイミングしかないでしょう！
質問コーナー、リクエストコーナー
ほぼリクエストコーナー
僕にこう言いたいこととか
なんか質問したいこと、やってほしいことがあったら
書く動画コーナーで～す
はい。ということで、
で、それをもとにして僕が動画を作るかもしれません
クリア！
もう一ページずつ潰していくからな
「絶体絶命」的な状況じゃないから
確実に、確実に。
一歩ずつ歩いていきますよ
あ、そうだ！
あの～「質問コーナーまだ？」「質問コーナーまだ？」
って言われるんですけども
もうね～
今日バシッと言いますよ
一月の
三日までには出します
一日に出せれば良いんですけど
１日は忙しくて～
分かんないんだよ
もうオレのね
ちょっと僕次第なんですけども
多分
出せなかったらごめんなｓ
とりあえず、三日ぐらいまでをちょっと目安に考えといてもらえると、ありがたいです。
もうテキトーなコメントでいいんすよ！
もう「あいうえお」
あ、そりゃねえや
好きなこと書いちゃってください
これをね～、まず言いたかった
今年はホントにねあの～
たくさんの方に支えられた年でした。
ホントにいつも応援してくださるみなさん、ありがとうございます。
ということで、一月三日までにはやるので
良かったら皆さん
コメントぜひぜひ書いちゃってください
今年はもうホントに支えられてるんですよ皆さんに
支えられてる分ですね
僕は
この目の前の
卒論をね
倒さなきゃいけないんすよ
お正月からもう質問コーナーをしていくスタイルに
ちょっと来年はいくので
皆さまのコメントお待ちしております
ついでなんですけど
「はじめしゃちょー２」の
セカンドチャンネルの方がですね
もうすぐチャンネル登録者が100万人いくんで
良かったらそちらもよろしくお願いします
ゲーム実況動画とか・ラフな動画・告知動画・ラフすぎたクソ動画とかもあるので、
よかったらそちらもチャンネル登録お待ちしております
では、みなさんのコメントを待ちつつ
僕は今夜も地獄のように卒論を励みます
じゃあな！